mmm
okay for people joining this live stream
it is the first of
three that we are doing today this one
is on the subject of
question objects and assessment
functions
uh for things like uh
educational quizzes and such all right
let's start off with the guide page here
so what am i looking at here am i just
yeah
it's a notebook i didn't want to commit
it because i thought it might
the name and stuff might change so it's
just in a cloud object
okay all right so let's get a sense of
what's here
so question object so so i mean these
things will mostly live in form
notebooks
yes i think so yes
q a form notebook which has yet to be
implemented
what do you mean by that well so far on
the road map we've discussed having two
different types of form notebook
form notebook and q a form notebook form
notebook having
insertion of form object and q a form
notebook having an insertion of
question object does that make sense
yes it does make sense okay so
so but i'm not sure we i think we should
be able to mix and match those things
right
why not i mean so in other words every
cell in a form notebook that allows the
possibility
of input so if i go here programmatic
notebook form authoring notebook
what you're saying is what happens if i
expand this
i think the configuration menu or
whatever we call the gear
is going to be a lot different and
that's the main reason we want two
different things
yeah but but
okay well but i i don't understand if
you want to
mix and match them if certain fields
like
fill in your name okay that's not an
assessed question
true right
so i i think we're going to need look
here
when we have i mean it says form element
great editable notebook area so why
isn't there
a question element well
i think question objects will
be able to not have an assessment
so you don't necessarily need to do that
and then it's it's very similar to
form objects we have a ux design process
going on for form notebook right now
so i'll make sure that this is included
in that yeah i mean i think that this
what would this look like for a question
object
i don't think it looks that different
does it well
you have to have the assessment function
which we need to allow arbitrary
complexity for i understand that but but
that's just another one of these fields
that is a code-like field yes these are
like fields
most of the time yes most of the time
you will be forced to have at least some
code for
to define the assessment that is the
idea that it wouldn't look
too much different right and maybe
there's a
way of selecting some common assessments
that are just
named yep so i think it will be
pretty much the same and i think we
should allow mixing and matching and i
think it becomes
a you know um
okay so it's a form element and then
it's a
maybe it's a uh you know question
element
is the other thing yeah i think allowing
mixing imaging makes sense but i think
the
quiz writing is a common enough and
custom enough use case that it's worth
having as
entirely well sure but but but right but
it's going to need free form fields like
what is your name
and so on yes yes yes yes yes but it's
not obvious to me
that it's any different right in other
words the thing is going to return
what would normally be just the
unprocessed or possibly interpreted
uh form field return will now be
processed by the assessment function
right that's really the only difference
you mean after the end user hits the
submit button
that's correct yes yes that's the main
difference right so i mean
running it through an assessment
function it's just like the form element
just has an identity assessment function
and the question element has a
non-identity assessment function and
that doesn't seem problematic to me
right conceptually i think that's uh
that makes sense fine
so and i think all the rest of this flow
is pretty much the same
so really what it is is
you know it's a and by the way one might
want to pick up
the raw things that people typed in
which i guess
can come through the assessment function
i think that's part of the association
for the assessment function right
but the main point is that you're auto
running a function
a specialized function on each field
which is the assessment function
yes and that's really the whereas here
in the standard uh you know form case
you're pretty much you know you're
running an interpreter but nothing else
am i making sense right okay
so i i think it should just be folded
into the same story right and yeah so i
mean
in the form notebook one of the major
things is you have to tell people
you have to specify what happens when
somebody hits submit
do you show just displayed another
notebook do you put it somewhere
for the question and answer one
typically
that will be predefined right it it'll
it'll assess it and reinsert mark up you
know it'll mark up the
the user's notebook
right i'm sorry sorry say again i lost
construct typically the the action that
happens
when it's submitted is is predefined
in the question and answer case yes you
know it's assessed and the notebook's
marked up
that's what happens you don't need to
worry say do we create a whole nother
notebook i see what you're saying so so
in other words what you're saying is
in these actions here where you say
well let's see submission button action
here
so one of those actions is markup
you know use the assessment functions to
mark up the notebook right that's
default that'll be the default
and yeah and fine
we should communicate strongly not that
you most people don't want to mess with
it
i understand that i understand so that's
but your concept is
that there's a q a notebook that is
different from a form notebook
that has that as the default action but
in a form notebook you could still have
that as the action
um well i think most of the fields in
the forum notebook wouldn't
have any built-in way to know how to
mark themselves up
i know but that's very simple they mark
themselves up by doing nothing
you know what is your name you know
whatever
one of the bottom choices here because
it's usually going to be
not very good well right it's only good
if you have a lot of assessment function
stuff
right right right okay all right so
that's a unified thing and we're just
providing a q a notebook
interface where pretty much
this would not be we would not mostly
have interpreters for the other fields
we would just have
freeform input fields right
and um i mean what happens when you have
a an assessment function that's running
on a chunk of notebook
do we have that we have a plan we
haven't implemented it but we have a
plan
okay yeah so that's the principle
possible the answer compares to methods
to be able to take
basically anything so far easy common
stuff
so you can write it so for example cells
cells could be a comparison method or
notebooks entirely no i understand that
but i mean we could have something where
the main assessment thing where it's
like you're supposed to write a
computational essay and it will use
some heuristics to grade your
computational essay and it'll give you
points off if you have for loops and
things
yeah yeah that's certainly in the in the
realm of possibilities okay it seems
like a
yeah sort of on the horizon of things we
want to approach
right okay all right let's take a look
okay so we're looking
okay question object we understand
assessment function is part of question
object
assessment result object is the thing
that comes back after the processing of
that correct
yes okay
so all updates uh
documented in cbs okay well what so what
am i supposed to see here
the assessment function there's there's
updates in the assessment function
page if you want to review
it's it's not major in assessment
function
sorry the updates are not major changes
to assessment function okay so what what
should i do what the main one is
uh cloud object so you can have an
assessment function of cloud object
which represents
a deployed assessment function boy this
is a complicated creature
right so right uh yeah
do the users get exposed to this
complexity or is it mostly in pull downs
i i mean i think most of this well
i mean assessment function they can dive
in as much as you want if they want some
if they want a complex assessment then
they'll probably have to learn this
stuff and they'll type an assessment
function into that
normally do we have the ui yet for
building a question
uh object for right because that's what
we want to be able to do
is there are all these things like it's
a geo position it's a data object and so
on
that should all be something that can be
done from the gui
right we don't have the authoring gui
for these made yet
but it will presumably follow the
principles of the form notebook
authoring gui yes
schroeder said right yeah what's that
yeah
yes that's the roadmap and that's what
we can bring to the next meeting
okay fine all right okay so should i be
looking at question object here
yes the question object is new um
oh yeah that's right assessment function
is actually in 12 2.
so some functions in 12 2 but it wasn't
very exciting so we didn't really
talk a lot about it yeah okay
okay question object
represents the question the
corresponding assessment
okay but so now the question
is there an example here
right so so you we have this convenience
where you can have a test function as a
second argument instead of a full
assessment function
it'll kind of build the assessment
function automatically for you
okay so between there's the operator
form of between
so wait a minute so this
is
okay i mean i understand how can no
okay so the the usual thing is that
there is a piece of style
text at the beginning and then
this is something that will be inserted
in the notebook with this form
and this is a style and they'll
presumably be a bunch of styles for
these things right
right right so this is the input field
style right
and you see in the next one you didn't
specify the style directly but it's
inferred
from the assessment what what
oh i see here but we didn't specify the
style here either
right the input field is the default
okay
okay fine i see and the second one
if that had been a geo if those have
been geo positions what would it have
done we don't know it might have a map
or something
exactly right right you might it might
be clickable or
yeah okay there's a lot of choices to be
made and it's not obvious
but you can always override it okay
question object
prompt order us presidents by
inauguration date question interface
multiple choice
grid why is this
not an ass sub association the question
interface
well the first element is not a rule
it's just uh
it's kind of like when we do sub options
and it's like a method sub option it's
that
sort of thing blah yeah we've also
we also have the idea of a question
interface object
that would be a cleaner i think that'll
be syntax
yeah and we want it yeah it's it's it
should be pretty easy to
implement it on top of this but
so the question of this object is
defining
so then of this is so so i'm trying to
understand how is this related to
you know could we how is this related to
our general user interface objects
do you understand what i'm saying no i
don't know what's interesting well so so
what i'm i'm talking about
is let's say you're building a
manipulate and you want these the same
kind of grid and a manipulate how would
you do it
well we want to make all of these
specifications available in the foreign
world as well
well then we shouldn't call it question
i mean we should call it just
some other kind of interface i mean it's
this is a general
this is look it's just like
it's more like an interface object
or what is it i mean it's an interface
object where
the goal is to get just like a slider
delivers a single number right
we should get somebody from the front
end team involved in this because this
is a
this seems like it's a generalization of
radio button you know
whatever they are you know all the radio
button functions and things like that
but it's a different form of it it's a
form where like if we had a slider here
what would it look like
i think there's an example with slider
somewhere
um is it further up
shorter we made this yesterday right
didn't you slide towards the top
oh yeah right it was the output's not
evaluated
um can i evaluate it yeah it should
yeah okay so
this is a mess if i might say so i mean
what we've got here
is something that is essentially a copy
of manipulate controls or general user
interface controls
but presented in a different form like
this object
you see what i'm saying this this thing
one one of the things
that led us down this route that we're
trying to achieve is that very often
some of these sub-option values can be
inferred from the
the answer of the assessment object so
it might be sufficient simply to say
slider and then it can figure out for
itself what the range is or
in things like the previous case with
the categories and the choices
those are all things that are available
in the assessment
uh function so we don't want to say
stuff twice so the idea is that in
simple cases you might just be enough to
say slightly that's fine
that's fine but but so is it in the case
of i mean
you know that that's exactly the same
thing in a form object
right you can say the controller type
right in a form object who knows how
that works
yeah i've done that before right so we
need to unify this
with whatever's happening there right
because because whatever we're doing
here
should just work in form objects
and and vice versa i've always found the
form object
syntax for those things difficult to use
well fine then let's invent something
that we can
you know have some more of an object
that we can put into both places
okay so right which yeah so maybe just
we what we have makes sense but the name
shouldn't have question in it
i don't know that it makes sense you
need to have something that is more
unified
with the way that this works in forms
okay so go figure out how it works in
forms and go come up with something
which is some symbolic wrapper that
represents this whole interface
construct
right i think that's what we have
planned for question interface but
the name is probably not
i'm saying yeah right we can do that and
we can reference both ricardo and
somebody from the front end team on the
design before coming
find you fine but then i would suggest
that this is more like a form interface
that's more like what this is about
because
but i'm not sure exactly what the you
know
i'm not sure so go figure that out i
don't know
okay so
change to partially specified keys okay
we have a few comments on our live
stream here
uh from ethan asking for levels of
successive hints
i don't know whether we have that what
is our hinting mechanism at this point
you know give me another hint how do we
do that
yeah we don't have a successive hits
we haven't implemented but it is on on
the roadmap because
um that's one thing from the question
framework in cbm that
we want to bring into this um where it
has a carousel of hints
okay fine
the hints would go in there just like
ranges in the example that you're
looking at right now
yeah you would i see you're specific so
the only question is a hint sequence
and any dependency of you know one could
imagine something
where the hints depend on uh what actual
things people have tried entering
do you see what i'm saying yes yep
but i think the the most minimal thing
is just give me one hint
and then there's a hint sequence but the
hint sequence in general
can depend on you know functions that
are applied to what's already been
entered
that's a question for me well is to
basically it feels like there's three
choices here there's
there's a list which is sequential hints
there's one which is just a list of one
hint and then there's a function which
would
yeah which would generate what you've
yeah yeah right would take what you've
entered and generate a hint from it
hint function hint sequence
hint hence sequence hint function but do
they need to be different things or is
it just a case of if the right hand side
is a function
we also have uh explanation
which is dependent that's different
on on the what the user puts in right
it's returned by the assessment
i know but that's after the fact that's
after you press well i see
right but if you're saying that a hint
that depends on what the user's done
that might be the same thing as an
explanation well no but it might it
would not be because there's a button
that says give me a hint
right if you specify a hint look there's
two cases there's
hint preemptively when the user presses
give me a hint
i don't know what to do and this hint
after they give a wrong answer
those are two different cases right
which i don't know the design of having
both of them on one thing is
up in the air certainly you might with
hints as well as one of the few things
like
where you might want to take stuff from
outside of the question
if you've got a sequence of questions
and you get one two and three wrong
oh boy that's adaptive learning and
that's fairly complicated
right i mean and i think then that
starts becoming linked to actually
changing the question you get next which
is stuff that we punted from
these early designs right that's not the
way up right now
okay right okay um question from ethan
how will deploying timed questions
securely work
i think we have uh i mean the secure
deployment
will work because all the stuff is on
the server right
right right so the we have this question
deploy function that's also on the
agenda
that will and and that'll be what's
basically powering
at least part of the gear menu on the q
a form notebook
you know i figure from there or another
menu next to it
we'll have a deployment mechanism where
but the timing mechanism we've also
thought about right
we've yeah yeah so that i mean when you
when you it should be pinging the server
um well also but but it also just has a
time stamp
and um you know then it can have an
entry time stamp and exit timestamp
right right but yeah but in order to not
fake it you need to
you need to you know touch the server
when you start and when you submit
right well for extra you know for extra
luxury features we can
send the data to our blockchain
that's yeah yeah
just to you know it's trivial to do that
it's just blockchain right
right if we want a world where
independent independent verification is
needed i think
um
okay uh also ethan is saying a loud
number of guesses do we have that
so there's this disabled reassessment
which might be the wrong name
um as an option that we're proposing to
add
to a number of these functions
so well i mean but
i think we just want a max tries or
something a max submissions
yeah that's yeah that's the same thing
um just a better name
okay
and it can default to one for oh yeah
i'm not sure the default should be one
or infinity
okay okay well
probably depends that's probably one of
the one things that would be set
yes i mean it's a look i think what we
need to do
is there are known scenarios like you
know a final exam
a um uh a kind of a
you know a history taking for medical
stuff a this or that or the other
right and um you know i think each one
of these
we need some kind of description
which is uh
i guess you know part of the point is
um to make a somewhat generic
description
and then put in our uh selector eg
final exam or something eg
you know test your knowledge quiz i
don't know the names of all these
educational
concepts i'm sure there are there are
things where there's you know
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
yeah and we should
and it'll be nice to have fully built
examples of them too that are available
right nick is suggesting the very
amusing idea of encrypted objects with
question objects as captures
that's an amusing idea in other words
yeah that's an amazing idea
uh i mean the other thing with these
is you know another case is a survey
well i guess that's not an assessment
thing that's just a form notebook that's
usually just can be a form notebook
right right okay
all right let's keep going here
assessment result object
right so the main this was in 12 3 it's
not something people write themselves it
just comes back to them
and the main change that we were adding
for i'm sorry adding 4123
is that a single assessment result
object can contain
multiple assessments so you can nest
them and it's sort of a single object
which is what we need for deployment
okay
i don't fully understand that but maybe
i will right so i mean there are two use
cases you can imagine deploying a single
question to a cloud object and it it's
pretty simple but you can imagine
deploying a whole quiz to a cloud object
yes to a single and so what does the
cloud object return when it's a whole
quiz
it still returns a system result object
but instead of being one level deep
it's it's two levels deep okay
why wouldn't it be three or four i mean
i don't understand why i mean it can be
it can be
arbitrarily but yeah but basically yeah
instead of just containing
you know you said three the answer was
four here's why you're wrong
it contains a list of this but i don't
understand why
how it would get more more nested
do you see what i'm saying in other
words is it the case that in a form
notebook
you know you're either describing the
result of a single form notebook okay
you're describing the result of a single
question in a single form notebook
or you're describing the result of a
bunch of questions in a single form
notebook
how do you get to do something more
nested yeah i don't i don't really have
a use case so anymore
well we're nested but implement the
implementation in the code allows for
arbitrary nesting
but i think in the normal use scenario
it's either going to be
zero one or two however you want to say
it i mean depending on how you do it you
could have your whole course
right you could have something where
there's this section of the exam
and it's you know this and it's you know
this question within this section within
this whole
you know i just hate to be the student
who has to submit their whole exam
their whole course with a single button
click
whatever that the whole you do get exams
that have sections though you get like
you know must answer three questions out
of section b and all questions out of
section eight
sure yeah yeah that that's a reasonable
scenario
but yeah this whole business about
teaching humans to act like computers is
just absolutely bonkers
and it's it's um i mean you know we're
doing it
more and more in the world today i it
really uh
it's like like all these things where
unless you put these words
your twitter account will be banned or
unless you um
uh you know have your english your essay
that's supposed to be an exposition for
about something unless it contains these
grammatical structures and these words
you won't get a good score
it's like okay fine well anyway
but let me not um uh
we're just building technology okay
uh what should i be looking at here
should i be looking at question object
or not we're just just looking at it
yeah okay but we didn't go through any
of these details
here right suggest supported interface
types
okay so so this is where we would have
the geo selector for example
yes yes okay and we want each of these
to have their own
documentation page which will be fine so
you're going to have a
list a list of um um
what are we going to have it's a listing
of question object types
there is a section for this and i wanted
to ask if it's too early to choose the
uri for these
i don't think so okay if you can choose
worst case we can we can
change it i mean yeah that's true
question object type i would say well we
were
saying maybe it won't have the word
question in it if this is a form
interface type
right said it again well i mean one of
the first things we said in this meeting
is
the term question interface might be too
specific maybe we need to rename it form
interface or something
yes fair enough all right fair enough
but but again you've got to merge it
with the existing ui
controls which
yeah all right so that that's a project
for you guys to straighten out
okay but as soon as you have it
straightened out you know form interface
type or whatever i mean
look if we have to change the uri so be
it
that's fine okay okay let's move on
question deploy right so this could go
in system or
it could work under the hood i'm not
i've i want you to what
it could just be an internal symbol
that's what is part of the
implementation
uh so it's like cloud deploy for a
question object
but instead of returning a cloud object
it returns the
sanitized question object so that so
instead of having an answer key
in the objective okay so listen this is
similar to what happens with mail
mail um mail receiver
right which returns a fake cloud object
which i've never liked
i don't like it either no yeah
so yeah i'm trying to avoid okay but
what we need we had a design for
something which is a proxied
cloud object right in the case of the
mail receiver
what's happening is we have a cloud
object which is the
the anchor point for the mail receiver
so for example it's the thing that
manages the mail receiver the mail
receiver itself is deployed in some kind
of mail system somewhere
um but the cloud object is
its anchor point and if you delete the
anchor point
it knows to go and delete the the actual
you know mail insertion so can we go
through what the question object thing
what this question deploy actually does
yeah so this is
so what it actually does is it takes the
assessment function and it deploys it
to a cloud object as a url dispatcher
actually where one of the endpoints is
an api function that does the assessment
the other is an info endpoint that just
tells about the assessment function all
right so this is analogous to what
happens with the metal receiver function
well no because the reason we're not
using cloud deploying the important
point
is that what it gives back is not the
cloud object
what it gives back is the modified
question object
that is in place of the assessment
function that has the
key hard-coded into it so anyone who
inspects it can find the answer
it has the cloud object so in other
words but it's also a permissions game
right because
somebody has the ability to get the the
full cloud object with its key
yes whoever deployed yeah right but so
so what happens is this is
two permissions there's a permission for
the
full deployed object and there's a
permission
okay so what this says is read versus
execute right
you can you can use all the clouds
yeah right so what it's doing is it's
setting
the permissions thing to be owner gets
read write and other people in the class
or whatever get execute and the rest of
the world gets nothing or whatever it is
right is that correct well i mean you
you that's how the permissions the
permissions object whoever you set
to have read access can see the answer
key and
import the whole thing whoever you set
to have execute can take can
take the quiz right
right now we didn't override we didn't
override
the default dollar permissions or
anything like that
one question here is the longer term
aspiration for the level of security
this should provide because i
i'm seeing this as as intermediate
security that the answers aren't there
in the notebook for somebody just to do
show expression on
but it is not for high stakes why
because you need a
and the reason is that for high stakes
we're going to need quite a lot more
machinery on the server side such as
we'll only accept one submission we'll
only accept submissions between nine in
the morning and midday on this date
and things like that so you can't
write yourself a little program to spam
it with answers until you hit the right
answer
well hold on so the main issue there is
that it needs to hold state basically
so it needs to know you've already had
to go and to know that you
that's it that's a separate piece of of
equipment so to speak
because that's that has to do with okay
so okay so here's here's the thing that
this isn't
right so our cloud object permission
system
just says can you read it doesn't say
oh you can only read it once between
this time and this time
now we do have our enhanced
uh uh cloud permission system which i
think has been largely implemented if
not completely
which has things like only from this geo
location
only between these times of day and so
on so we have that yeah the one that
will take care of the timed exam where
you have to do it at the right hours but
this count thing would work this is a
read once
type thing how many times can this user
read it
that happens to be a permissions case we
have not considered but i don't think
there's any reason we couldn't have that
in other words the the the metadata
database
for the cloud can perfectly well store
the number
okay but i think that the message for
them is that we want
a read once permission okay
right for a given user it's like like
it just hasn't come up before but
there's no reason we can't have that
i don't think we need read twice
do you agree implementation i think it's
considerably easier to do read once
and i think it's incomprehensible for
people to say read end times
well what the hell let's see whether we
can do it we need a
an easy reset tool yeah though that's
very quick
as well what happens if you screw up and
you beg to your team
yeah how do they reset it by going into
the permission system
and you just reset i see what you have
to do so what you have to do
is wipe the flag that says that user x
is right
the admin needs to do set permissions on
cloud object of user one goes to read
once again
yeah the problem is that how yeah but
okay but the issue is
and read once will just
be something yeah right they probably
that will be the way you would reset it
uh and also it you know in terms of how
you set it up you might not be saying
user x
uh is allowed to read this once you
might be saying class x which is a user
permissions group
can read once which has to then yeah
expand out all of that
you could do an individual for the reset
you would just do an individual reset of
that particular user to read once
anyway this is something for about that
group to deal with
okay okay
all right um
okay so then we're talking about how to
deploy
this thing which is going to come back
with only
a piece i mean this is really
more similar to mail receiver than i
think you're giving it credit for
because i see what you need is the
consumer part of this has to come back
right actually you need both parts you
need two parts coming back
you need essentially a consumer
interface you know what what should come
back
maybe is something like some of the
cryptography functions or some of um
you know it's basically this pair the
consumer interface
you know the the public interface and
the private interface
yeah what i'm saying i see yep um
so because it's useful to have the cloud
object as well and and the other part of
this
that is also important about what it
comes back it doesn't just remove the
key and insert the cloud object
it also if there's interface information
that is inferred
from the assessment function it extracts
that
and puts it back into the return cloud
object correctly
so if you need to know what are the
multiple choice questions and if it was
in the notebook it would just infer them
from the assessment function
now the assessment function is gone you
can't look into it
so we need to extract that information
and move it into the question
interface okay so i've got a question if
you
cloud deploy a form notebook a form
authoring notebook
okay what are you getting back don't you
have the same issue there that you want
both the
the consumer form and the authoring form
to be part of the cloud deployment
do you see what i'm saying
i think it's the same issue and i think
we should solve it in the same way
that is that we have a
some kind of it's not quite form deploy
but it's some kind of um uh
you know some kind of doubled cloud
deploy
okay maybe it's a um
maybe maybe it's a um an option or a
second argument to cloud deploy well
that's at the uri
i don't know it's probably a new
function okay that that essentially
returns
and i this would solve the mail receiver
problem too
okay it would return multiple things
in an association where you could pick
out oh i just want
the mailing address or i just want the
cloud object proxy
okay and i think i had a design for this
and if we can look for that that will be
good
um okay i mean it just uh uh
maybe was it in the context of mail
receiver function
it was it was in the context of okay
what it is
okay it was in the context of service
deploy
which mail receiver function is an
example of okay
okay and i claim that this is also an
example of that so
service deploy is something where you
are
let's say you want to put a twitter bot
out there
okay you are service deploying it
because although it may have a cloud
object that is its anchor
the ultimate service is deployed
somewhere else
i i understand which should be yeah
there's definitely parallels to mail
receiver function and service
to play i understand where you want to
return this public and private pair
yeah email receiver function the public
thing is just an email address
exactly so hacking it into the cloud
object wasn't so terrible
in this case it's a complex computable
expression
so yeah you're not going to do it you're
not going to hack
but hacking it into the cloud object is
a hack it is
yes but it was a hack that kind of sort
of worked in that case
because there was a clickable link and
you could just use yeah but
in this case that's never going to work
so maybe what we want to do is have
service deploy be
the general function that does these
things since you're you know you're
deploying
a you know a question response service
you're deploying a mail receiver service
etc etc etc
and service deploy then you know always
returns an association
that would be my first my first take on
this
okay and i believe there was a service
deploy coming in 12 30
is that well i service deploy has been
discussed
okay and i'm trying to remember what um
service deploy
has is that something christian's group
is making
oh boy what's this service deploy
service object what the heck is this
this an action schedule this is a
different thing
oh this is to like retrieve all the
tweets about hot dogs once an hour
yeah this is like a task sort of thing
yeah this is a different thing
so maybe oh no no you know what this is
used for
this is used in the bloomberg link yeah
financial
data yeah right so maybe maybe we need
something other than service deploy we
need something which is
um it's not external deploy
it's
interface deploy
possibly i don't know if that's general
enough
um but and this but
in in our case we are talking about the
cloud
right it's deploying it to the cloud
yeah but
i think we want to deal with the mail
receiver case which is deploying it kind
of to the cloud
right it's deploying it to an external
service that is connected to the cloud
that's part of your system servers list
you see what i'm saying yeah but it's
not actually
i mean conceptually you know does it
live in the same data center
probably not necessarily is it part of
a private cloud probably
not necessarily you might have set your
system servers list
to have your you know this functionality
handled in your private cloud this other
functionality handled centrally etc
makes sense right but yeah this service
to play is
different right it's it's not okay can
you guys vote brady can you go chase
down i think that is probably a
christian
production sure um
and i know for him was involved as well
okay right and and probably that's not
what we can use
but it is something like that that we
want to use i mean it's a
you know what it really is is more like
an end point deploy but that's kind of
an ugly name
do you see what i'm saying yeah i'll try
and figure this out
right i could imagine like cloud service
to play
for possible yeah that's possible
that is possible that is a possible name
yeah i agree that's a reasonable
possibility all right
so so okay so but the the basic result
whatever this is cloud service deploy
it's going to return an association or
maybe a cloud service deployment object
or something i'm not sure a cloud
service object
actually that's an interesting idea just
as we have a cloud object we could have
a cloud service object
that's actually an interesting idea that
can have multiple tentacles
that you can connect to do you see what
i'm saying
yes and then then it's symmetrical it's
cloud deploy gives you a cloud object
cloud service deploy gives you a
cloud service object and a cloud service
object
has you know has almost always an
element of it will be
a cloud object right and but but and
also
a cloud service object unlike
a yeah you see here's what we've got to
do a cloud
deploy has a permissions you know has a
single permissions
a cloud service deploy has a more
complicated permission structure
because you may want to say i want this
group of teachers you know
this group of professors and tas to have
access to this
and this group of students to have
access to that and so on
does that make sense and for example i
might even have you know a registrar who
has access to some completely different
set of
permissions it has a more complicated
permission structure
and one thing that we need to say is
acceptable in the case and this
for it to work for this case is the
cloud service object is not
necessarily retrievable from the cloud
at a later date right there's
post-processing that happens
in cloud service to play that does
what do you mean it isn't retrievable i
mean that there's going to be a
management interface like delete object
has to be possible
right you can yeah yeah sure you can
delete but i'm saying so
like the what we have in question to
play right now returns this marked up
question object their modified question
object
right you might not be able to reproduce
that modified question object
just starting from knowing where the
cloud object was deployed
it may not be possible okay well so
export it as another element i mean
yeah right right over the cloud service
but like with
a cloud object you know a cloud object
is a cloud object of the cloud object if
you know the url you can retrieve the
whole thing and it's all good
in this case there's a there's a state
in the returned object that's important
to track
potentially right okay i think i get
that but but okay look i think we have a
path forward and i think it's a pretty
good path
and please talk to the cloud object team
about how this would work for mail
receiver
okay okay um
harry on our live stream suggest remote
deploy that won't work because we have a
whole bunch of remote evaluate things
and remote deploy
will be similar to local deploy and
it'll be a way of putting we don't have
it yet
but just like local deploy is a way of
putting we will be able to deploy
certain apis that run against wstp
server on a local computer as opposed to
against a cloud uh
creating essentially a local api rather
than a cloud api
so i would expect that to do the same
thing for a remote device
maybe scheduled task might benefit from
this as well
yes it might get we still testing
objects right we still have a task
object that's still a thing right
that's absolutely yeah but the fact that
so you could get this
cloud object or the task object which
would be really useful that would be
really useful
right good i knew we needed such a
framework
a good scheme okay so let's um i mean
that's yet a separate group of people
that deal with the topic
yeah so that means that means brady make
sure dylan b is on
whatever you send out okay
disable the assessment we just discussed
that's max what do we call it
um
max submissions max submissions yeah i'm
sorry i haven't been taking notes here
and it needs to have a dollar setting as
well and we need to know all the use
cases and make sure we can support them
and then the selector put eg file
exam etc well that's a different thing
for the whole
whole object okay all right give target
answer
what is this so in the assessment result
object
do we want to include stuff that might
tell the user what the right answer is
or do we want to hide it right both
both are reasonable use cases right
what's the right one what
what are you saying what so it says
enter the answer here and then it has
underneath the answer is two
right you you might you might want to
fully explain to people why they got
something wrong right and and and say
well the right answer the right answer
was broccoli
and you said cauliflower and here's why
it's wrong or you might not want to tell
him any of that you might
just want to say kyle flowers wrong
no i understand is that just a specific
case of explanation
i would where it might be some text that
says the reason why it's two is this so
it might just say the answer is two
explanation are automatic or something
right but yeah but there's also
interface reasons why you want the
computable form of the correct answer
right if you're
imagining you're clicking on a map and
you want to show an x
of the correct answer in an x where i
don't know right
i don't know what give target answer is
not the best name but i
yeah i i don't know what the complete
constellation of those names is let's
not look at that right now
but i agree that this is a useful
function piece of functionality
do you need a name right now i mean use
gift card
yeah it's a string right now we don't
need a document we can leave it in as a
string and change it later
okay okay this is
this is what we've already discussed
right here he talked about yeah
okay form panel what is this
this is some this is
similar to what question object is going
to do
but without uh with with
where the user specifies all the markup
rules where it's not coming from an
assessment function
have sort of a low level thing where you
can say like a form object or form page
well that's the thing i was saying
earlier
that this whole elaborate thing that
you've got going wherever it was
um what was it
this this whole elaborate thing that
you've got here
this is something we should be able to
provide in any
form related system setup
right is this what you're talking about
here well there's one for just
specifying the
there's two parts to it they're
specifying the interface
i'm talking about this part the
interface part yeah yes so specifying
the interface
would think yeah we were going to call
it i have a symbol called questionnaire
effects we're talking about renaming
that something more generic
but then there's also a tool where you
can
where it's a dynamic object with with
you know that self annotates
okay that sounds like a user interface
element please talk to those people lou
or somebody
right yeah yeah yeah i think that
isn't we need somebody from that group
to
be part of that conversation or even do
the implementation
right but how that gets unraveled
you know you've got two different things
one is a dynamic object
that stores its state as like you know
slider of x you know slider of dynamic
of x
is taking the dynamic value of x and
using that to display the slider
right and the second case which
we didn't build in the original ui build
out 20 years ago
was the case where but which is
effectively used
in forms and to some extent to
manipulate
is the more uh is the non-dynamic form
of just referring to a slider
you see what i'm saying where something
else is going to hydrate the slider
right and in the way of doing it through
the dynamic system
right the slider is is hydrated by its
argument
right from the inside does this make
sense right that is not what we specced
out for form panel
i i understand so you've got two
different versions of this you've got
hydrate from the inside slider dynamic
of x
and you've got hydrate from the outside
as in
you've got something which says the you
know form control
arrow slider and something completely
different is going to bring that to life
do you see what i'm saying yes yes uh
yeah the
the external hydration mechanism we
discussed the form panel is
when you click the the submit button it
regenerates itself
based on what you've done well but
that's not
but you see the yes but the thing is the
main thing is as you move in slider
dynamic of x
as you move the slider it changes the
value of x
right right this is something different
this is a thing where you're describing
the interface
but it's a one-shot thing where you set
the interface up and then you say press
go
see what i'm saying so it's not a
dynamic interface in the same way
you're talking about question object or
form panel question interface
both of them i mean all of them the
things that look what happens inside a
form object
is the same thing yeah
what we specked out for form panel was
not a one-shot
thing it didn't have that dynamic
variable backing
okay but it look the this this
conversation needs to have
the right we've already had this
conversation yeah but okay
try to get these people to to define
you know we we want a close analog
between
the dynamic version and the non-dynamic
version
okay probably the same functions and we
have that to some extent to manipulate
and and we have notes from another
meeting where we spec out foreign
okay anything else that we need to go
over here
um i think this
so this is like the content that will go
into those that new doc page
form right this is okay sort of just
keeping track of stuff
i am supposed to go to another meeting
which is another live stream
about logic programming so um
we've definitely accomplished enough to
not keep you from another meeting
okay maybe i even get something to eat
for a minute beforehand
okay